la fiche à l'entrée de la maison de
retraite de poissy donne le ton ici les
fortes chaleurs sont redoutés pour l'été
et le plan canicule a déjà été activée
depuis le 1er juin
l'objectif éviter aux résidents de se
déshydrater
nous sommes très vigilants sur les
températures donc il ya un contrôle de
température plusieurs fois par jour et
on adapte bien sûr notre nom de
fonctionnement en fonction notamment les
fermer les volets tirez tirez les
rideaux fermés les fenêtres pour que la
chaleur ne rentre pas et préserver au
maximum les espaces dans lesquels ils
évoluent au quotidien la salle de
restaurant et climatisées tout comme les
chambres des résidents qui dispose
également de ventilateurs et la
nourriture est adapté avec plus de
fruits et de produits frais quant aux
soignants les effectuent des tours
d'hydratation il propose un verre d'eau
toutes les heures où 104 résidents de
l'établissement un plan canicule c'est
surtout à essayer de motiver les
résidents à boire à s'hydrater apporte
aux secours et à la station personnes
âgées donc on a des soucis avec leur
thermogénèse parce qu'ils connaissent
pas est sombre il oublie qu'il fait
chaud donc suivant il ya beaucoup qui se
couvrent un peu trop donc on est jeune
on a demandé aux familles de leur
apporter des vêtements clairs maintenant
que ton soupe et puis ensuite on les
crayons les hydrates le plus possible la
maison de retraite ouvre aussi ses
portes aux aînés des alentours
eux aussi peuvent venir profiter des
installations mises en place et se
rafraîchir